what we've read of this deal it doesn't
meet our expectations it creates a
border down the Irish Sea between
Britain and Northern Ireland and it
leads once again to erase to the bottom
in rights and protections for British
citizens and the danger a bigger pond
sorry a danger of the sell-off of our
national assets to American company
could you vote for it if a confirmatory
referendum was attached to it we are
unhappy with this deal and as it stands
will vote against it though obviously we
need to see all of the last details of
it it wouldn't be a nice chance to get
it all passed like get on the most
important thing is to have a good
relationship with Europe in the future
which means that a good trade
relationship and it's also very
important from the Labour Party's point
of view to absolutely protect the rights
of protections that we've obtained
through membership of the European Union
and to ensure that we have an effective
trade relationship with Europe because
half of our traders with Europe and
particularly in the north of England and
large numbers of manufacturing plants
rely on trade with Europe and so as this
deal stands
we cannot support it that's something
for the future relations agreement not
what a withdrawal agreement the
important thing is to make this decision
now before we take any steps forward and
stands we will not support this
agreement that the Prime Minister has
apparently reached today it also appears
to be a very high wire act because he
doesn't have the support apparently of
his own allies in Parliament have you
given up on your hopes of renegotiating
brexit deal
not at all a Labour government elected
in a general election would within three
months negotiates an agreement with the
European Union around the five pillars
that have often set out which are of a
customs union trade relationship
protection of rights and of course
protection of deeds will you sorry too
excited it's a very exciting time
protection of the of the Good Friday
Agreement and then within six months we
had put that to a referendum under a
Labour government so will you bring a
motion of no-confidence under the fixed
term Parliament's Act this weekend this
weekend is that weekend to discuss the
Prime Minister's agreement that he's
apparently reached that will come out of
today's summit and Parliament will vote
on that on Saturday afternoon I think
other issues err for next week